Wow
hmm
despite the Yakuza series cult status
mainstream success has always eluded it
in the West if you've never played a
Yakuza game before however Yakuza zero
is a logical place to test the waters
it's the series debut on PlayStation 4
and has a prequel of the first Yakuza
game it doesn't rely on pre-existing
knowledge of its principal characters
more importantly you should play zero
because it's a fascinating game that
combines equal parts drama and comedy
and is unlike anything else after such a
statement is worth scrutinizing so to be
clear its zeros flaws that we've out to
you at first glance be it some seriously
outdated character models and textures
or the repetitive nature of combat but
were some elements languished from a
lack of attention to detail other facets
of zero are masterfully executed take
the story for example which jumps back
and forth from the perspective of two
different Yakuza on opposite sides of
Japan kiri u Kazuma is a young Yakuza
gangster from Tokyo with an iron fist
but a heart of gold and he's caught in
the middle of a battle between criminal
organizations seeking to take control of
a valuable piece of real estate on the
other side of the country in Osaka we
meet goro majima a disfigured Yakuza
masquerading as the manager of a grand
cabaret also on the outs with his clan
Majin was sent on a mission to kill a
troublesome business owner but soon
finds himself unable to complete the job
for personal reasons zero takes its
storytelling seriously nobody cracks
jokes or makes empty threats as such the
story is relentlessly tense proving to
be equal parts surprising and exciting
from the beginning to the end
[Music]
you come to here
[Music]
while the game is only playable in
Japanese with English subtitles the
energy and attitude behind most
characters doesn't need to be translated
bosses or more appropriately captains
are often rendered with photorealistic
facial features as well some textures go
too far revealing what looks like
extreme cases of clogged pores but
blemishes aside zeroes key characters
look just as convincing as they sound
navigate in the wha-whoa a genome to
continue almost across the board however
zeros other characters exhibit middling
animations most NPCs look as though they
were lifted from the series PlayStation
3 entries if not from a PlayStation 2
Yakuza key given that moving through the
story missions is only half of the
Aquajet experience this is a reality you
have to confront on a regular basis
Hanahan combat is another key component
of zero that feels dated despite any
improvements made upper past games both
cure you and majima feature different
fighting styles three varieties of peace
but zero straightforward beat-em-up
trappings ultimately grow repetitive by
and large you can choose one fighting
style that works for you and focus on
that for the entire game the enemies you
face on the street are somewhat diverse
and include the likes of lonesome drunks
bikers and lowly Yakuza thugs
thematically the variety is appreciated
but mechanically most enemies fight the
same
at least zero is nothing if not a
brutally violent game you will grind
enemy's faces into the pavement stick a
bat in their mouth and kick the exposed
end and piledrive thugs skull first into
the street and special takedowns like
these add a necessary amount of flair to
combat saving fights from becoming truly
Road more you play the more apparent it
becomes that zero wants you to feel both
like a badass Yakuza and like a
participant in an absurdist comedy no
one will argue that a Yakuza on the run
has time to pretend to be a random
girl's boyfriend to impress her father
or stand-in as a producer on a TV
commercial but the game's 100 ridiculous
side stories are excellent palate
cleansers that often elicit a chuckle
make you scratch your head and amusement
and refresh your perspective traditional
for the series zero also doesn't shy
away from thrusting you into erotic
situations be it in the form of softcore
porn video parlors or in a minigame that
involves betting on wrestling matches
between two scantily clad women at best
you can momentarily excuse its
quote-unquote tasteless pursuits as a
reflection of Japanese society in the
late 80's or accept them at face value
as erotica stereotypically however
Yakuza view women as objects to be
manipulated and this issue can't be
avoided if zero aims to present a
realistic Yakuza tale just don't expect
the game to address it in a meaningful
way otherwise zero relentlessly adheres
to his Japanese roots mostly for the
better and if you've ever traveled to
Japan the game sights and sounds will
instantly trigger fond memories and
feelings of nostalgia so unless you have
a strong aversion to violence sex or
middle and graphics you really owe it to
yourself to give zero chance its story
will surprise you its inhabitants will
make you laugh at every turn and its
ambitious scope will redefine how you
think about open-world games it's a
fascinating adventure no matter how you
approach it and proof positive that a
game can be wildly inconsistent yet
remain a great experience
[Music]
you
[Music]